testons vos connaissances sur la
rétrofacturation
vous avez commandé un bien sur internet
avec votre carte de crédit et vous ne le
recevez pas pouvez-vous demander une
rétrofacturation à votre émetteur de
carte de crédit
non pas encore parce que vous devez
d'abord exercer votre droit d'annulation
et demander au marchand de vous
rembourser et combien de temps avez-vous
pour demander au marchand de vous
rembourser
[Musique]
toute la vie il n'y a pas de date limite
pour annuler cette transaction mais
sachez que dès que vous demandez au
marchand de vous rembourser le compteur
démarre
il a 15 jours pour réagir après ce délai
si le marchand nous a pas répondu là
vous pouvez exiger la rétrofacturation à
votre émetteur de carte de crédit
attention en Ontario ça s'applique aux
achats de 50 dollars et plus seulement
dernière question combien de temps
avez-vous pour faire cette demande
[Musique]
60 jours après ça trop tard donc le
marchand à 15 jours pour vous répondre
après quoi vous avez 60 jours pour
exiger la rétrofacturation passer le mot
[Musique]